was geht hier vor max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video ihr seht
schon in meinem hintergrund ich bin mal
wieder bei mir zu hause und das ist für
mich unbegreiflich wirklich ich war
jetzt sechs wochen unterwegs auf diese
sechs wochen habe ich genau zweimal bei
mir zu hause geschlafen das fällt euch
vielleicht auf erstens daran dass nicht
so viele videos kamen aber das ist ja
relativ normal bei mir und zweitens
daran dass ihr nie diesen hintergrund
gesehen habt ihr könnt mich auch gerne
mal wissen lassen ist das aufgefallen
dass ich die ganze zeit unterwegs war
oder ist das euch überhaupt nicht
aufgefallen ich erzähle euch auf jeden
fall mal wo ich so unterwegs war
übrigens ihr seht ja schon im titel dass
ich betrogen wurde das ganze kommt etwas
später weil es halt zum späteren
zeitpunkt innerhalb dieser sechs wochen
passiert ist also wenn ihr wissen wollt
worum es geht dann bleibt dran
ich dachte mir ich erzähle immer
vielleicht so ein paar kleine stories
und was wir jeweils gemacht haben und
zeigt euch dazu falls ich was habe
irgendwie ein paar bilder oder die
ersten zwei wochen nordseeurlaub wie
jedes jahr zusammen mit meinem bruder
und luca und vielen anderen freunde
jedes jahr dort sind ja es war sehr heiß
also wir hatten mittelmäßiges glück mit
dem wetter
erste woche war ganz nett zweite woche
war sehr bescheiden und ja das waren
halt die ersten zwei wochen wo ich weg
war in der zeit habe ich ja eins habe
ich ein paar videos gemacht aus dem
urlaub mini basketball und bei luca
instagram bildern abstellen und so
weiter und so fort also da dürfte tier
so mehr oder weniger auf dem laufenden
gewesen sein da habe ich zum beispiel
dieses instagram foto gemacht und ihr
seht schon meint ihr handy zerbrochen
aber naja was solls nach diesen zwei
wochen an der nordsee kamen so
allmählich die video das ich wünsche ein
paar tage vorher nach köln gefahren war
da in der neben meiner freundin wohnt
und ja habt einfach ein bisschen zeit
verbracht ein bisschen gefehlt weil aber
auch nicht zu hause
und ja dann kam die video des da habe
ich dieses wunderschöne foto von ihr
seht ich wie viel wie ich vor der video
des menge stehe als grablichter an wand
daran glaube ich hat die lobbys auf der
bühne und ja ich bin sehr sehr schönen
blick drauf
die video days waren ziemlich cool
dieses jahr ultras war einfach wie bei
luca sich das ganze entwickelt hat so
war letztes jahr hat der luke er gerade
eine million autos erreicht und er war
schon alles
archiv crazy so wenn luca unterwegs war
aber wenn man sich mal überlegt er bis
jetzt fast seiner aber nicht verdoppelt
ja also bei luca was wirklich ultra
krass so weil alle sind immer total
ausgerastet wenn er in der nähe war ich
selbst habe auch ein paar von euch
getroffen ich habe zum beispiel ein
parcours bezeichnung bekommen oder
irgendwelche anderen geschenke so und ja
video days waren auf jeden fall eine
sehr nette erfahrung ich finde auch
immer cool so dass man als zuschauer ist
nicht so mitbekommt das sind halt
einfach immer so viele gute partys um
die video days herum und ja da hab ich
glaube ich insgesamt neun tage oder
sowas in köln verbracht weil wieder im
anschluss auch noch dieses nerv in
handschellen video gedreht haben so nach
diesem neun tagen köln bin ich für zehn
tage nach italien gefahren
jetzt komme ich auch auf diese ganze
story die im titel steht wir haben als
in italien kleinen tripp gemacht
sebastian und ich habe meine mama und
unsere schwester eingeladen hat auf den
urlaub einfach um den so ein bisschen
was zurückzugeben und hatten also einen
kleinen rund trip geplanten italien drei
tage an einem ort an dem sie drei tage
in der nähe von venedig und drei tage in
triest wo er mein austauschpartner ist
und italien war super cool hier haben
wir ein weniger schönes foto von mir wie
ich irgendwo eine grimasse mache vom
himmel
fragt mich nicht warum ansonsten ja hier
foto von sebastian am see zwar auf jeden
fall echt nice ein kleines war schön so
viel zeit mit der familie zu verbringen
übrigens habe ich auch meine instagram
story so ein bisschen geführt während
dem ganzen trip also wenn ihr mir auf
instagram folgen wollt da mache ich
zurzeit meine stories ich überlege ob
ich mir vielleicht auch snetterton soll
ihre waren wie ein paar tage am see und
jetzt kommen wir auch zu der ganzen
story vom titel
wir dachten uns youtube videos machen
und internet was auch immer dazu gehört
muss ja irgendwie trotzdem auch wenn man
im urlaub ist einfach weil wir das ja
nicht nur als job machen sondern weil es
uns auch mal spaß macht up to date zu
bleiben und deshalb darf man uns holen
wir uns eine internet karte und für
diejenigen unter euch die es nicht
wissen ich spreche italienisch ich hab
das von der achten bis zur zwölften
klasse in der schule gehabt und kann
also ich kann nicht ganz gut
verständigen auf italienisch man kann
definitiv verstehen was ich sagen will
wenn man in diesem italienischen
geschäft leona daily ist es glaube ich
ich habe schon zwei mal als ich da
vorteil da habe ich mir schon
italienische sim karte geholt weil er
einfach das datenvolumen so ultra
günstig ist du kriegst glaube ich 15 gb
für lasst mich nicht lügen 15 gb kriegs
glaube ich für zehn oder 15 euro
das ist halt der traum für jeden der in
deutschland wohnt und diese ultra teuren
preise hat für internet ja deshalb
wollten wir uns dieses jahr wieder so
eine karte holen sind in diesen
elektronikladen der da halt in der nähe
war am see gefahren leonard ellis island
sind wir reingegangen ich meine
italienische chelsea am oder cds ja wir
haben ob sony oder steam italiana
blablabla habt ihr mal erklärt ok wir
kommen aus deutschland wir machen so
eine rundreise über gesagt geh morgen
fahren wir weiter und wir brauchen alle
sehen wie sofort klappt und er meint
okay dass das machen wir hier für euch
fertig hier 20 gigabyte daten könnt ihr
euer iphone reinmachen dann gibt der
eine dem anderen hotspot bei meinem
bruder unterwegs und dann hat 20
gigabyte daten und zahlt dafür 30 euro
wir so kay á 30 euro ist jetzt nicht so
günstig wie ich das in erinnerung hatte
wie davon wir machen das mal einfach
dass wir videos schauen können wie ich
schon gesagt habe dann rede ich mit dem
er hat dann sebastians ausweis kopiert
und so weiter hat halt den vertrag
fertig gemacht meine sehr einmalig 30
euro 20 gb und dann gehen wir zur kasse
und der typ sagt erstmal 40 euro was
schon mal voll komisch war aber wir
wollten nicht irgendwie ein großes fass
aufmachen unsere mutter und schwester
auf uns gewartet weil wir da ewig drin
waren und uns beraten lassen haben von
diesem typen und haben gesagt okay alles
klar dann sind 40 ist ärgerlich aber wir
bezahlen trotzdem sind dann raus
gegangen
sebastian hat sich die sim karte
eingebaut und es hat alles funktioniert
so ist ein bisschen wasser als macht
keine ahnung bis ins netz ein bisschen
sonstwas und am nächsten tag hat
plötzlich things you anlässe so
nachrichten auf sein handy bekommen hat
er scheint also drin du hast ein
guthaben werden muss sein guthaben
aufladen
wieso
was für guthaben wir haben einmalig
bezahlt und dann lässt sich das selbst
wieder auf und dann wurde er wirklich so
voll gesperrt er hat glaube ich
insgesamt im ganzen urlaub wohl wieder
unterwegs waren 150 solcher nachrichten
von diesen von diesen aus diesem laden
bekommen so von wegen
du musst wieder aufladen du musst wieder
aufladen er wurde einfach zu tode voll
gesperrt die haben das bestreben ja ein
guthaben ist leer wären es einfach
ignoriert weil wir hatten ja mit dem im
laden alles besprochen und dann wollte
sebastian irgendwie was nachschauen oder
sowas auf youtube und dann haben wir
festgestellt dass internet funktioniert
nicht mehr
und wie er so richtig ab gefragt weil
wir waren schon weitergefahren wir waren
irgendwie drei stunden zwei stunden
weiter schon die nähe von venedig
gefahren der laden hätte auch nicht mehr
aufgehalten werden echt keinen bock
zurückzufahren das hotel in dem wir dann
waren hatte ein ultra ultra schlechtes
internet so dass man überhaupt nichts
hochladen konnte über das wlan und wir
waren da und einfach nur sauer weil die
uns irgendwie beschissen hatten und dann
sind wir in eine nahe gelegene stadt
gefahren waren irgendwie auch ne halbe
dreiviertel stunde oder so was unterwegs
bis wir da waren weil dann in und
vodafone shop wir haben halt eine
sim-karte von vodafone bekommen und
haben unsere problematik geschadet meint
okan uns dass verkauf und so und er so
her was ihr euch verkauft haben es gibt
gar nicht und wir gucken würde annehmen
so roma in gott weil dann wussten wir
halt wirklich die haben uns verarscht
die amis betrogen wenn man zu diesen
vertrag den wir euch gesagt genannt hat
gibt es erst mal nur mit 10 gb dann hat
er sich halt unsere sim-karte angeschaut
und so meinte ja okay ihr habt 10 gb
wir haben zehn gigabyte img niemals
aufgebraucht wie so können wir kein
internet benutzen und dann meinte er
ja ihr 10 gb allerdings nur für tablets
wirklich ist war so mies so ich sage ich
hab so zwischen italienischen vodafone
berater gemeinsam hoffentlich der typ
der uns das verkauft hat uns betrogen
hat sport hoffentlich zur hölle weil wie
mies ist das so du kommst als touristin
an russland traust dich den
gewissermaßen an und sagt zoe wir
brauchen das und das könnt ihr uns bitte
beraten hat quasi so eine chance
gewittert um uns einfach abzuziehen also
richtig richtig mies und ja deshalb
hatten wir im ganzen italienurlaub kein
internet ich habe bei meinem deutschen
tarif möglich
mein normales internet weiter zu führen
was aber in zwei euro 90 pro tag kostet
oder so das heißt ich habe insgesamt
noch mal 30 euro bezahlt dafür und hatte
auch noch ein halb gigabyte datenvolumen
und ja das war behindert deshalb konnten
wir halt nicht so wirklich aus italien
videos hochladen was auch mit grund
dafür war das bei mir halt nichts kam ab
und war aber dass ich irgendwie nicht so
diese ganzen diesen familien urlaub so
durch fünf stunden videos machen am tag
belasten wollte danach bin ich von
italien nach dem wieder unseren runde
fertig hatten nach salzburg gefahren von
salzburg bin ich nach berlin geflogen
damen den letzten dreh gemacht habe mich
am nächsten tag nach düsseldorf geflogen
haben wir was für bb gedreht und dann
wenn ich einen tag nach köln zu meiner
freunde dann waren wir zusammen drei
tage in hamburg und der 29 packen können
und bin heute endlich wieder
zurückgekommen ich hinterher dieses
ganze reisen cool und weißt du auch zu
schätzen aber es war wirklich schön
jetzt nach sechs wochen wo ich mehr oder
weniger gar nicht zu hause war das echt
schön mal wieder nach hause zu kommen
also ist es echt nett ja leute das war
meine story
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen oder ihr
fahren als interessant oder was auch
immer das mich gerne mal wissen wie ihr
diese ganze geschichte bewertet dass die
uns einfach betrogen haben da in italien
ich werde probieren paar mehr videos zu
machen die nächsten tage und ja bis dann
instagram folgen